teachers in England and Wales will go on
strike tomorrow after last minute talks
with the education secretary failed The
Joint General Secretary of the National
Education Union Kevin Courtney is with
us now hello to Mr Courtney thanks for
joining us on the program just speaking
to the minister representing the
government this morning he says that
your teachers are being irresponsible
well he's completely wrong the
government is letting our children down
there is ongoing disruption every day in
our schools since covid they appointed
Kevin Collins as the recoveries are he
gave them a program that we agreed with
it would have cost them 14 billion
pounds they refused to do it they cut it
down to less than a third we are hearing
stories every day of special needs
assistance leaving jobs in schools to
work in supermarkets leaving children
without support every day of GCSE
classes being taught by somebody who
doesn't have a qualification doing their
best but being taught by somebody who
doesn't have a qualification in the
subject of primary classes where there
are successions of temporary teachers
because they can't hold on to permanent
teachers there's disruption every day in
our schools because the government isn't
investing in our schools or the people
who work in them
how appropriate is it though that
teachers are not sharing what their
plans are with head teachers so that
they can make plans for youngsters
tomorrow
well I think it's very appropriate you
know if this was the pandemic if it was
another natural phenomenon we would be
doing everything we could to make sure
schools were running as much as possible
but the point about tomorrow is that
it's a strike it's a strike because
we're in dispute with the government
we're in dispute about that disruption
that's happening every day in schools we
want our strike to be effective in order
to concentrate the government's mind
we've done everything the law requires
of us and the laws in this country are
extremely strict around trades unions so
head teachers know how many Neu members
at least they know how many Nu members
there were at this when we when we
notified them the number has gone up
quite a lot actually but we've given
that information to heads that's the
information that's required of us
actually do you know most head teachers
are supporting the their unions are in
the same position of being in dispute
with the government about these
questions and they want the action to be
successful they want the pressure to be
on government to change so that things
get better for the children in our
schools
so what do you hope to achieve by not
telling head teachers what you plan
well as I've just said we hope that we
want our strike to be effective tomorrow
in order to concentrate government's
mind we're in dispute the next day of
strike action is February the 28th but
we're hoping to we're hoping to avoid
that next day of strike action we're
hoping to avoid the next day of strike
action or after that on the 15th and
16th of March we want the government to
concentrate and come to the table and
bring proposals that can help us resolve
the dispute by helping us ensure we have
enough teachers and special needs
assistants and Tas in our schools so
that education isn't disrupted every day
the way it is at the moment I understand
that Mr Courtney but I'm asking
specifically by not telling head
teachers what the plan is what do you
think will happen tomorrow
well head teachers should be planning on
the basis that Neu members are on strike
and we've given them that information
and they can plan on that basis
but it could mean that some Neu members
go in some don't some kids might get to
school and then be turned around and
sent back again what what I don't
understand
well I don't think that will be the case
in very many situations lots of schools
will have made a decision to close some
will be keeping some classes open
because some teachers will have told the
head that they're going to in in school
on that day but the whole point of this
is to put pressure on government to come
to the table so we can stop the
disruption in schools that's happening
every day we want our strike to be
effective it's not the same as a natural
phenomenon where we would be like covid
where we would be doing everything we
could to make sure that schools were
running as well as possible we are in
dispute we are on strike our members are
giving up their days pay for a noble
Purpose By the way of trying to
improve education by improving the
funding and the pay of the people who
work in our schools but they're giving
up their pay for a noble purpose we want
their sacrifice to be effective we want
government to feel that they have to
talk to us so that there isn't another
strike on February the 28th March the
1st March the 2nd March the 15th 16th
the dates that we've identified we want
to avoid those strikes and that means we
want this strike to be as effective as
possible
why did the talks fail yesterday
well because uh because the minister
brought no proposals whatsoever to the
table they're nothing whatsoever on pay
this year or next year
no suggestion of a non-consolidated lump
sum no suggestion of a pay rise on the
other hand we took to her a
comprehensive set of data from bodies
that aren't unions pointing to the
relative decline in teacher pay since
2010 as a real problem for Recruitment
and Retention we took a paper by Luke
simbietta for the ifs suggesting that
teacher pay has dropped while average
pay in the economy has increased we took
a paper by public first a right they've
sent a think tank which says that
teachers and social workers have
suffered the worst during this period of
wage suppression we took a chart from
the Sunday time saying the same we took
information that we'd got um that we
developed that the financial times run
with showing a sharp decline in in
teacher pay compared with average
compared with the the sort of averages
in other professions since 2010 those
things really matter to teach a
recruitment and retention we took in the
report from the national foundation for
Education research which says the
government's pay proposals will not
solve the problem on teacher recruitment
and retention